I don't even know what the hell you guys
are talking about that song but I know
it's about gangsters no it's really
about it's my life because you living in
the gangsta's paradise also see what
your business is not really controlled
you know
gangsta's paradise is when you're being
controlled in yes well not when I was
riding it it just made me you know that
LV was singing the track and I walked in
and I was like damn how I really like
this oh I love it and LV let's do it
come on come on how can we do do we have
a choice with the track right here hold
on one second
I got to see LV sing though man I got to
see that have you ever seen all these
things yeah isn't it amazing yeah I hold
on wish it let me play the track you
sing all right okay UNLV all right here
we go
Shh check this out this is gonna be
really good I'm really excited about
this listen he's got enough
[Music]
as I walk look gather up the shadow of
Jeff I take a look at my life and
realize there's nothing left just I've
been laughing and laughing so long that
even my mama thinks that my heart lets
go but I never crossed a man that didn't
deserve it me be treated like a punk you
know that's unheard of you better watch
how you're talking and where you're
walking
or you and your homies might be lined
and so I really hated [ __ ] but I got a
look as the coke I see myself in the
pistol smoke fool I'm the kind of G the
little homies wanna be like all my knees
in the night prayers in the spending
most their lives living in
[Music]
[Music]
they've got the situation they got me
facing and I can live a normal life I
was raised by the state so I gotta be
down with the hood team too much
television watching got me chasing dream
on my educated fool with money on my
mind back tear in my hand and a gleam in
my eye i'm a loc'd out gangsta set
trippin banger and my homies is down so
don't arouse my anger fool death ain't
nothing but a heartbeat away I've never
liked do a guy what can I say I'm 23
never will I live to see 20 both away
they just go and I don't know tell me
why are we so blind to see here that's
the ones we are you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the money money and the power
minute after minute hour after hour
everybody's running but have another
look at this going on in the kitchen but
I don't know what's cooking they say I
got to learn but nobody's here to teach
me if they can't understand how can they
reach me I guess they can't I guess they
were I guess they put that's why I got
my hand on the purple ring spending most
our lives living in the gangsta's
paradise not even spinning
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
living in live most Our Lives living in
the gangsta's paradise our baby we live
in most our lives living in the
gangsta's paradise been living most Our
Lives living in the gangsta's paradise
and what's our babe we've been leaving
most our lives living in the gangsta's
guys and no gangsters night to
Portuguese okay Rock writer